by rowman & littlefield on the web at
roman littlefield dot-com
in the 1990s the world Commission on
dams was formed to examine the effects
of large dams on their surrounding
environments Jacque Leslie details what
they found in Australia Africa and India
his new book deep water this talk from
Copperfield's books and Santa Rosa
California is an hour thank you very
much it's a pleasure to be here and it
is a privilege to have had the
opportunity to write this book it deals
with a couple of things that I care very
deeply about one of them is narrative
nonfiction I grew up admiring people
like Gay Talese John McPhee Joan Didion
and I was thrilled when I got the
opportunity to emulate them in this book
and the other subject that I care very
deeply about is the environment I have
tried for many years to write about the
environment I wrote many proposals to
magazines and it wasn't until 1999 when
Harper's assigned me to do a piece on
global water scarcity that I finally got
a chance to do something substantial on
the environment and having spent the
next six months working on that piece
and ending up with something that ran as
I think it was 15,000 words I'll try to
sum up those 15,000 words in just a few
and at the risk of great
oversimplification the population of the
world now is six and a half billion
people by mid-century it will reach
eight or nine billion people at the same
time the amount of fresh water at our
disposal will remain constant of all the
water in the world only about two and a
half percent is fresh water
the rest is salt water and of that two
and a half percent two thirds of it
is tied up in glaciers and ice caps so
we're really talking about less than 1%
of all the water in the world that is at
the disposal of humans and already we've
had tremendous regional shortages and
the thought of what will happen when our
population grows by another 25 or 30
percent is extremely worrisome we've
already tried to deal with it with
short-term solutions that have very
severe long-term consequences
let me just add already we have 1.2
billion people who don't have access to
clean water we have 3 billion people who
do not have access to sanitation no
toilets no latrines really no nothing
that's almost half the people on the
planet 5 million people die a year from
easily preventable waterborne diseases
and so we're already in a great deal of
trouble now these solutions that are
have long-term negative consequences
start with depleting groundwater all
around the world water is being taken
out of the ground and used mostly for
agriculture with no thought of how it
will be replenished and it will run out
it is rapidly running out in many places
one of them is the Ogallala Aquifer that
extends from South Dakota to Texas in
the United States it's also true in
China and in India India there are
places in India in the state of Tamil
Nadu for instance where the water table
has dropped about a hundred feet because
of all the the groundwater youth that
has gone on and it goes on at the rate
of something like three to seven feet a
year at a very dramatic pace and if that
can't go on much longer it will reach
the point where it either becomes too
expensive to pump that water or weather
or where
the water simply isn't there the other
way in which I'd say that we're engaged
in something with very dangerous
consequences is by building dams we have
built 45,000 dams that are over five
stories tall around the world they have
displaced 40 to 80 million people that
is people who lived where the reservoirs
would be and who were shoved aside by
the reservoirs usually without much
thought given as to where now there are
resettlement programs sometimes but
they're rarely carried out the way
they're planned they usually result in
disaster having said that let me read
you the prologue from the book or at the
beginning of the prologue start with the
primal dam Hoover the first dam of the
modern era is America's Great Pyramid
whose face was designed without
adornment to emphasize its power to
focus the eye on its smooth arcing aw
inspiring bulk yet the dam nods to
beauty with a grace that grows more
precious year by year its suave art deco
railings fluted brass fixtures and a
three-mile long sidewalks with of
polished terrazzo granite floors are the
sort of features missing from the purely
utilitarian public works projects of
more recent decades Hoover is a
miraculous giant thumbnail that happens
to have transformed the West take it
away and you take away water and power
from 25 million people take it away and
you remove a slice of American history
including a piece of the recovery from
the depression when news of each step in
the dams construction the drilling of
the diversion tunnels the building of
the earth and rock coffered and the
digging to bedrock
the first pour of foundation the
accretion of five foot high cement
terraces that eventually formed the face
hardened hungry and dejected people
across the country and you take away the
jobs the dam provided ten or fifteen
thousand workers
whose desperation compelled them to
accept risky exhausting labor for $4 a
day more than 200 workers died during
Hoover's construction the dam and Las
Vegas more or less vivified each
other.if hoover evokes glory las vegas
only 30 miles away is its malignant twin
even now hoover provides 90% of las
vegas water turning a desert outpost
into the fastest-growing metropolis in
the country by all means take away las
vegas take away hoover and you might
also have to take away the allied
victory in world war ii which partly
depended on war planes and ships built
in Southern California with its hydro
electric current and take away modern
Los Angeles San Diego Phoenix you
reverse the twentieth-century shift of
American economic power from East Coast
to west take away Hoover and the dams
that spawned on the Colorado Glen Canyon
Davis Parker head gate rock palo verde
all the way to Morelos across the
Mexican border and you restore much of
the American Southwest landscape
including a portion of its abundant
agricultural land to shrub and cactus
desert above all takeaway Hoover and you
take away the American belief in
technology the extraordinary assumption
that it above all will redeem our sins
at Hoover is September 30 1935
dedication interior secretary Harold
Ickes exactly reflected the common
understanding when he declared
pridefully man acclaims his conquest of
nature
Hoover's image became one of the
nation's most popular exports after it
every country wanted dams and every
major country regardless of ideology
built them between Hoover and the end of
the century more than 45,000 large dams
dams at least five stories tall were
built in a hundred 40 countries by now
the planet has expended two trillion
dollars on dams the equivalent of
the entire 2003 US government budget the
world's dams have shifted so much weight
the geophysicist believed they have
slightly altered the speed of the
Earth's rotation the tilt of its axis
and the shape of its gravitational field
they adorned 60% of the world's 200 plus
major river basins and the water behind
them Watts out at terrain bigger than
California their turbines generate 1/5
of the world's electricity supply and
the water they store makes possible as
much as 1/6 of the Earth's food
production take away hoover dam and you
take away a bearing a confidence a sense
of what nations are for yet that's
what's happening
even if hoover lasts another 1,100 years
by which time Bureau of Reclamation
officials say lake mead will be filled
with sediment turning the dam into an
expensive waterfall its teleological
edifice has already begun to crumble in
seven decades we have learned that if
you take away hoover you also take away
millions of tons of salt that the
colorado once carried to the sea but
that have instead been strewn across the
irrigated landscape slowly poisoning the
soil take away the Colorado River dams
and you return the silt gathering behind
them to a free-flowing River allowing it
again to enrich the downstream wetlands
and the once fantastically abundant now
often caked arid and refuse fouled Delta
take away the dams and the Copa Indians
whose ancestors fished and farmed the
Delta for more than a millennium might
have a chance of avoiding cultural
extinction take away the dams and the
Colorado would again bring its nutrients
to the Gulf of California helping that
depleted fishery to recover the status
it held a half-century ago as an
unparalleled repository of marine life
take away the dams finally and the
Colorado River returns to its virgin
state tempestuous fickle in some
stretches astonishing
now in the mid-1990s the World Bank
which was the world's largest fin unsere
of large dams found itself in a great
dilemma it had had a number of Fiasco's
related to its dam projects and it was
finding them harder and harder to build
chiefly because groups that opposed the
building of these large dams led by the
International rivers network in Berkeley
not far away from here
realized that although their resources
were a tiny fraction of those of the
banks that if they could tie up these
projects in long delays very often
investors lost interest grew impatient
and pulled out of the projects and so
the bank in its frustration finally
reached the point where it agreed to a
proposal the dam opponents had made to
create an independent commission to
study the impact of the banks dams over
the bank's history and to come up with
recommendations for how they ought to be
built in the future and so the bank
agreed to play a key role the chief role
in the creation of what became known as
the world Commission on dams this
commission was independent it
represented people on the entire
spectrum of views about dams they were
taken from all over the world and when
the Commission was created there were 12
commissioners involved and there they
sorted them out by putting them in three
categories anteye dam mixed and pro dam
and then they drew four from each group
so that they would have a balanced
Commission now many people thought that
such a diverse Commission could not
possibly come up with a consensus and
produce a final report but they worked
very hard and seriously over two and a
half years and in November 2000 they
produced a 400-page report which was
which represented the most serious and
thorough study ever done of dams there
had been one change that the bank had
insisted upon and that
instead of just studying bank dams they
wanted this to be a study of all large
dams and it's probable that they did
this in order to divert attention from
their many failures in dams so this is
what this report covered it was
extremely thorough and it was
surprisingly critical of dams given its
the constitution of the Commission it
spoke of a marked tendency towards
schedule delays and cost overruns it
said irrigation dams didn't typically
didn't recover their cost it spoke of
environmental impacts that were more
negative than positive and in many cases
led to irreversible loss of species and
ecosystems and it said that the large
dams have led to the impoverishment and
suffering of millions giving rise to dam
opposition when this report came out the
bank which had previously been very
enthusiastic about the Commission
suddenly turned its back on its own
creation and said never mind we want
nothing to do with this and it then
embraced a policy which it has tried to
develop a since then of once more
building a large dams as quickly as it
can now the report stands as a kind of
best operating procedure about how to
build dams no countries have yet
embraced it although some are tiptoeing
up to it but it does remain as a kind of
standard by which all dam projects can
now be measured for a writer it also had
an advantage in that I saw that I could
borrow the Commission structure and so I
chose one commissioner from each of
those three categories Pro dam mixed and
anti dam and wrote about each of them in
action as they contended in very
different ways with dams and that's what
this book is about it's a portrait of
these three people in action so I'll
read you the beginning of the second
section which is about Ted Scudder an
American anthropologist who did
bulk of his work in southern Africa and
that's where I joined him and went with
him to several projects that he had
worked on and I should mention that the
other two commissioners I wrote about
were made of pet car probably the
world's foremost anti dam activist a
woman in India who opposed a huge dam
one of the two or three largest dams in
the world in western India and Don
Blackmore a chief executive of the
murray-darling Basin Commission in
Australia where the Commission oversaw
the only major river system in Australia
and it was severely depleted about
three-quarters of its flow had been
diverted to farmers primarily and so his
job became to try to persuade farmers
and politicians to return some of that
water
alright so Ted Scudder professor Thayer
Scudder the world's leading dam
resettlement expert did not want to go
with me to Zambia more precisely he did
not want to accompany me to Missoula the
village in Zambia where for nearly half
a century
he prana called a social catastrophe set
off by a dam at its completion in 1959
the dam an artless slab of arched cement
named Kariba rose the equivalent of a 48
storey building above its Zambezi River
floor it was then the biggest dam in
Africa and formed the world's largest
reservoir which instantly became the
world's largest man-made thing Kariba is
the first large dam financed by the
World Bank which lavished on it the
largest loan in the first decade of its
history from the air the reservoir
resembles a giant caterpillar with
tributaries four legs it obliterates a
hundred seventy-five miles of upstream
river and an average of 10 miles of
terrain on either side on that alluvial
soil enriched with sediment borne from
Africa score that Tonga of the goombah
Valley had survived for thousands
perhaps hundreds of thousands
of years to make room for the reservoir
the dams British colonial builders abreu
today Tonga two-thirds their entire
number and forced them into resettlement
sights on barren land in 1956 before the
dam was finished Scudder spent nearly a
year in Missoula conducting an
anthropological study of its 6,000
citizens in the four and a half decades
that followed he paid 18 extended visits
to them in the resettlement village
called Numa Zulu Elizabeth Coulson
Scudders mentor who led the study and he
took turns visiting the resettlement
area until they'd conducted the longest
running study of a dam social and
environmental impact in the beginning
Scudder had no inkling that he would
document a disaster he believed in dams
even as he constructed miniature
coroebus and termite mounds to show
Missoula villagers how their land would
be inundated they reacted with quote
great merriment and disbelief at the
thought that a structure sixty miles
away could affect them it wasn't until
the mid-1970s after the villagers it
seemed to recover from the shock of
resettlement only to founder that
Scudder realized his job consisted of
charting the disintegration of tonga
culture now he calls involuntary
resettlement quote the worst thing you
can do to people other than kill them in
the spring of 2002 when I was proposing
the trip Scudders Missoula informants
reported that village residents were
demoralized and hungry and Scudder
lacked the stomach or perhaps the heart
for a first-hand look he said we could
go to lassoo to the tiny African Kingdom
where he was ending a 13-year stint as a
consultant on a huge dam project and we
could visit Botswana where he played a
crucial role in stopping a dam that
would have harmed the Okavango Delta
a Connecticut sized puddle of
astonishing wildlife but at mizzou loo
he said there is little to see I'd have
to go there without him and indeed I did
Scudders distress was as much
intellectual as emotional it arose not
just from watching villagers of long
acquaintance suffer and die though that
registered it was in a way more personal
more fundamental because it aided the
assumptions on which his career and
dance is based again and again he
admired a dam and plan lent support to
its canoe its construction as consultant
and then after documenting its failures
of implementation and its social and
environmental damage grew disillusioned
his disillusion that has spread to his
frequent employer the World Bank for
failing to enforce its own resettlement
and environment policies but it stops at
the threshold of economic development
itself the conflict in his mind it's the
concept of development in which he has
always believed against all the evidence
he has gathered of its failures if dams
the centerpieces in every development
project that includes them repeatedly
failed to produce environmental
stability or even a modicum of economic
justice then what is left of development
and if development fails as it so
spectacularly has in Africa then what
will fill the gap between rich and poor
what will prevent a billion or two of
the world's poorest people from
unrelenting suffering and hopeless
squalid death for Scudder a kind of DAG
hammarskjöld internationalist a
successful dam would confirm a worldview
at seventy one he was still looking for
one good dam now as I said the book is
about these three people but it's also
about landscapes indeed as I traveled
with these people to the places and
projects that they were involved with I
was constantly being amazed by the
spectacular landscapes that I saw and
when I started writing about them my I
grew excited as I found the opportunity
to describe these places so I'll just a
redo one passage that's the beginning of
the Australia section that gets it a bit
of that
on a long driving trip from one end of
Australia's River Murray to the other I
turned off the highway near the town of
Loxton to stretch my legs and found
myself at a Riverside campsite staring
at a singular river red gum tree it was
surrounded by irrigated long and
distinguished from other red gums closer
to the river by a square log railing
around it red gums of the continents
emblematic tree the most prevalent of
more than six hundred eucalyptus species
that have thrived by evolving strategies
to cope with Australia's Seir
surroundings the red gums advantage is
its intricate root system both shallow
and deep that enables it to take water
from floods in the minority of years
when they occur and to absorb
groundwater the rest of the time they're
Hardy trees that live hundreds possibly
thousands of years the sweep of
Australian history from Aboriginal to
European domination is etched on their
trunks though still living some are
called scar trees because they bear the
vacant outlines of canoes shields and
plates that aboriginals carved from
their trunks and others display the
survey markings of the basin's 19th
century European explorers the tree I
beheld was a majestic specimen eighty or
ninety feet tall its branches were wide
enough to create an amphitheater 'he's
worth of shade and it's thick trunk in
the midst of Appeal resembled an urban
wall layered with weathered posters the
storied Murray some twenty-five yards
beyond the tree looked disappointingly
tame the pale green water that moved
through it at a stately pace would never
be confused with the torrent and the red
gums along at shallow banks were dwarfed
by the tree in front of me it looked
grandfatherly
as if protectively extending its limbs
over the campsites inhabitants Tree of
Knowledge a wooden sign said and beneath
that in smaller letters flood levels
when I moved closer I saw that the
trunks lower third was arrayed with
small metal placards each labeled with a
a year the 15 placards represent
three-quarters of a century of
significant River Murray floods and each
placards location on the trunk denotes
the height of that year's flood 1970 was
posted just a couple of inches off the
ground barely visible beneath the wooden
sign a cluster of placards appeared up
to a yard above the sign
Konoe ting the small and medium once a
year to once every 10 years floods the
engines of biological health that
replenish the Murray basins creeks lakes
and groundwater farther up six or eight
feet above the ground loomed the big
flood years of 1974 1975 and 1931 and
towering over them at the astonishing
height of 25 feet or so the placard for
the once-in-a-century 1956 flood which
in some places lasted two years it's
indicative of Australia's breath
swallowing aridity that the murricans
constitutes the largest channel of the
only major river system on the continent
yet its yearly flow is less than a day
of the Amazons nevertheless the Murray
Basin is Australia's heartland it's
Mississippi Valley where aboriginals
lived for 50 or 60 thousand years before
colliding disastrously with European
settlers and where the settlers farms
and ranches overtook the landscape to
the extent that many Australians still
think of their country as agricultural
I'd already noticed that quite a few
riverfront towns possess some version of
the Tree of Knowledge usually in the
form of flood years and heights posted
on building exteriors they reflect an
understanding that floods and droughts
right the region's history staring up at
the 1956 sign on the tree of knowledge
the most casual onlooker might have
tried to imagine how water could rise so
high over the broad floodplains flat
terrain a more attentive observer might
have noticed that the last flood
memorialized on the tree occurred in
1993 more than a decade earlier but
without an understanding of the Murrays
recent history he could not have
appreciated the ominous
sniff against of the gap and so what I
did was in Australia was to begin to
explore the reasons for that gap and to
to summarize very quickly what happened
is that the dams at the very top of this
river system helped to divert so much
water that it was now getting a little
more than a quarter of its natural flow
and the trees were not getting the water
that they would normally get in small
and medium floods it was estimated that
there would have been probably three of
these small or medium sized floods over
the eleven years since the last flood
had actually occurred but they were no
longer happening and these trees even
though in a natural environment they
lived for hundreds of years were not
able to stand up to this so it became
the job of Don Blackmore the fellow I
wrote about in Australia to try to
persuade the farmers and politicians who
were diverting the water that they
needed to put some back and so in the
book I described how he went about that
now the best-known of the commissioners
I wrote about is made a Pat car this
woman in India I first saw her in action
at something called the World Water
Forum which was held by the World Bank
in The Hague in 2000 it was meant to
focus people's attention on water and
maida and Arun daddy Roy the Booker
Prize winning author of the god of small
things this a very flamboyant woman I
circulated together and gave a press
conference together and in some ways
they were an odd couple
Arun daddy Roy is very elegant she wore
of casual western clothes her English
was flawless
whereas meadow was was nothing like that
and at first I was much more impressed
by Arun de tiro than Maeda
and we do how I
began to change my mind
Mayda seemed as relentlessly Indian as
Roy was cosmopolitan It was as if she
were wearing plaid in a polka dot
universe
she was formal ideological impersonal
and unceasingly serious
she was the frumpy graying scold in the
faded sari
many of her comments took the form of
denunciations of Dan's the World Bank
globalization all pieces of what I later
understood as her movements Gandhi and
Chomsky and feminist mother Teresa and
worldview she did not flirt she made no
one smile her speeches were variations
on the little engine that could she
spoke softly at first as if headed
uphill then huffed and puffed seeming to
draw energy from the active oration
until the Pistons churned and her hoarse
voice grew loud and the accusations flew
she said privatisation didn't
acknowledge the contributions of local
people the people who tended the forests
and got displaced by damned because they
weren't investors she said privatization
rewarded cash crops which meant that
poor people who depended on subsistence
agriculture went hungry
nearly yelling she said states now are
puppets of the World Bank and the
International Monetary Fund then the
mountain climbed the point made she
stopped it wasn't until a year later
when I spent a month in Cape Town the
headquarters of the world Commission on
dams that I began to suspect had gotten
things backward the Commission
Secretariat members were mostly water
experts few of them believed that the
dam debate was as one-sided as Maeda did
and they weren't noted particularly for
humility or godlessness yet they spoke
about Maeda with awe a hint of reverence
as if simultaneously acknowledging her
stature and vulnerability everyone
called her by her first name
even the engineers and capitalists
across the ideological abyss who are as
enthusiastically Pro Damned as Maeda is
aunt I treated her gently it was
understandable they said that Maeda
would fight for displaced people but
their plight did not invalidate Dan
most people spoke of her toughness her
determination her willingness to suffer
I learned that Maeda declined to eat her
meals during a flight to a commission
meeting - in Cairo and gave the food to
Cairo Street children after disembarking
I was told that Maeda attended one
Commission session immediately after a
week-long hunger strike and threw up
everything she ate a staff member of the
eventually found her some plain yoghurt
which he kept down and I was told that
during the heated last weeks of
negotiations over the Commission's final
report Maeda was the only commissioner
who won as the price of her signature
the placement of an individual comment
at the reports end in which he boomed
the Commission's refusal to consider
dams relation to the quote unjust and
destructive dominant development model
globalisation of the commissioners Maeda
was the best-known the most outspoken
the most politically sharply defined yet
against all the odds she was the most
admired and in a certain way cared for
the impression I gleaned from the staff
members in Cape Town was that while a
wounded deer oi wrote passionately about
the immorality of the norm of the dam
project Maeda embodied morality I went
to see Maeda as she made an attempt to
drown herself in the rising reservoir
waters of the Sardar Sarovar dam this
was this monstrous dam in India that she
began protesting in 1988 it when it is
built to its complete height and it's
now about fourth is there it'll reach
about 450 feet and it will displace
together with a canal attached to it
some two or three hundred thousand
people Maeda had tried once before to
drown herself as a times before to dot
to drown herself as a kind of protest
she thought that if she died in this way
the Indian government would be so
embarrassed that it might reverse itself
and reconsider its zeal for dams
and once when she tried the water got up
to about right here to her chin at which
point police barged into the hut where
she and her followers were gathered as
the water was rising pulled her away
from her followers and arrested her and
detained her until the water fell but
that didn't deter her from trying again
and so that's why I went to see her
together with a an environmental
photographer named Bob Dawson and we
slept on the ground in a hut with her on
the edge of this Norman a tributary
where she had posted herself together
with six or eight villagers in this
little hut and got a chance to spend a
lot of time with an extraordinary woman
and an inspiring woman and Bob and I
tried to be as inconspicuous as possible
and I'll read you a passage about that
Bob and I had already decided to pass up
the Andolan meals the movement meals out
of our fear of illness instead we
retreated to the hut sat on the mat and
tried to eat our own food discreetly
well made us at across from us having
skipped the meal to make another pass
etre documents we self-consciously
consumed American manufactured energy
bars and multinational bottled water It
was as if in the heart of the heart of
the anti-globalization movement we were
globalization moles eating became a
surreptitious act out of our unease
about being noticed we discovered the
noisiness of first world packaging
removing an energy bar from its wrapper
was a fundamentally loud act issuing a
crackling static that intensified in
proportion to our increasingly frantic
efforts to find weaknesses in the energy
bar defense in the end I pried the
wrapper open with my teeth to the energy
bars vibraphone the plastic water bottle
played bass we'd gulp the squid only to
hear the bottle booming Lee start to
implode startled we'd remove our lips
from the bottles mouth and with an even
louder thong
a clap that would resume its former
shape Maeda gave no sign of noticing now
Bob being a photographer wanted to take
a picture of the dam and so we visited
Indian officials in the town of Baroda
who had to do with the dam and ask
permission to get a tour of the dam and
for Bob to take pictures and we would
took we were told there'd be no problem
and then when we actually got to the dam
the officials there told us indeed there
was a problem and that Bob would not be
able to take pictures but they
magnanimously offered to let him take
pictures of the dam model a kind of 20
by 20 foot sand box that showed
something that looked vaguely like the
dam and so Bob did take pictures of the
dam model and then we went and saw the
dam
we heard the dam long before we saw it
it sounded like an unceasing earthquake
part rumble part roar it was the loudest
dam I ever heard we drove around a hill
taking note of one in a series of no
photography signs when suddenly we found
ourselves looking down on the dam it's
gargantuan in the model it looked tame
and inert like a thick inverted V but
the real thing loses power here is
contemporary cultures version of a
pyramid cold and geometrical the
antithesis of life's curvy essence the
perfect sheet of water that spilled over
the dams wide lip broke into thousands
of angry white rivulets that fell twice
the height of Niagara Falls before
hitting the bottom the water's force had
already eaten holes into the dam cement
catch basin and forced the construction
of humps atop the spillway to soften the
falling waters impact at the dams base
the water spewed and hissed and sent up
vaporous white clouds that obscured the
dams bottom third engineers called this
water hungry because it has shed its
sediment in the reservoir and thus will
corrode the downstream riverbank in its
search for a new load the intensity of
the green in the hills
the dam deepened from farthest range to
Stoppard River I tried to imagine the
river without the dam our guide mr. Shah
a deputy engineer was extremely proud of
the dam I asked him a question or two
about its technical aspects and he was
delighted to expound he got so wrapped
up in explaining his colleagues unique
solution to the dams foundation problems
that he didn't notice when Bob slipped
away retrieved his camera from the car
and shot some images of the dam through
the guardrail
now finally I will read you a passage
from the epilogue to the book we erect
dams assuming that they are eternal as
if they'll never topple over or be
dismantled or fill with sediment or lose
their financial rationale yet all dams
will die all that remains unknown is the
manner of their passing whether they
will be drained and safely put out of
operation decommissioned in the lingo or
will out of indifference or misjudgment
or an act of war collapse to the
enormous peril of all beings downstream
dams are of course loaded weapons aimed
down rivers pointed at ourselves they're
proof of the gambling nature of the
societies that build them imagine these
dams in five hundred or a thousand years
after their useful life has ended when
an earthquake from the fault line
beneath Sardar Sarovar fractures it or
the bankruptcy of Zambia and Zimbabwe
leads to Korea's fatal neglect or three
gorges fills with sediment or Kotsay
gets too expensive to maintain and when
every one of them suffers from an
altered hydrological regime as a result
of climate change
take your pick of mortal scenario
cumulatively they're more plausible than
the assumption that mega dams will be
successfully financed adroitly managed
and properly maintained into perpetuity
some dams will crumble into the basins
from which they rose while others may
still be intact but
longer storing water which instead runs
over or through or around them they'll
be relics of the 20th century like
Stalinism and gasoline-powered cars
symbols of the allure of Technology and
its transience of the top-down growth at
all costs era of development and
international banks of the delusion that
humans are exempt from nature's dominion
of greed and indifference to suffering
if there are tourists then they'll
circulate through the ruins as they now
inspect the pyramids awed by the
structures technological prowess and
unimaginable cost the people who lived
around the dams will have been dispersed
of course and their culture shattered
and the rivers and their valleys may
still be depleted but the dams
ephemerality not the rivers will then be
on display there'll be reminders of an
ancient time when humans believed they
could vanquish nature and found
themselves vanquished instead I just
would like to add that there are
photographs and a bibliography for the
book on my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com
[Music]
the a subtitle being dams displaced
people in the environment do we draw a
comparison now with New Orleans levees
displaced people and the environment and
what are your thoughts and reflections
on that they both involve the control of
nature in a way what's happened in New
Orleans is the opposite of what's
happening with dams but the result is
the same
there the Mississippi River has been
channelized the sediment which would
have gathered in the land that used to
be between New Orleans and the Gulf of
Mexico instead was shot out into the
Gulf of Mexico with the result that all
that land eroded and has now virtually
disappeared at the rate of something
like 30 square miles a year the the
attempt the idea that we can master
nature that we can impose our will on it
to such an a tremendous degree as I
think the fallacy in the thinking both
with this kind of effort the
channelizing of the Mississippi and with
the dams and there's one other thing as
well a very often governments like to
build dams because they're big they're
prestigious they cast glory on the
government's that build them even though
they they cost in the billions of
dollars indeed Three Gorges in China
will cost fifty billion dollars I've
even heard an estimate of seventy five
billion dollars a vast amount of money
but governments are much less
enthusiastic about doing the maintenance
that these huge things require and
that's what happened in New Orleans we
neglected to do the maintenance of the
levees it's not glamorous there's
nothing sexy about it and indeed
President Bush found it very easy to cut
the Corps of Engineers requests for
repairing those levees I think in one
year it was from fifty million dollars
to five million dollars
so the warning is the same I'd say in
both cases yes I wonder if you could say
a little bit more about the the
commission's report on dams and the
framework that was proposed for a better
way of looking at it looking at dam
construction
I mean there were in the 26
recommendations yeah
the recommendations ranged from the
common sensical such as something that
seems obvious to me which is that before
going about building a dam the people
who are building it first ought to do a
very serious Options assessment and make
sure that there is no cheaper way to
achieve the same means whether it's
water storage or a hydroelectric power
at a fraction of the cost and at a tiny
fraction of the environmental damage
you'd be surprised how many times a cess
Mazar not done before dams are built at
the other extreme that the probably the
most controversial of the
recommendations was that indigenous
people who are going to be whose removal
is proposed ought to be able to give
their informed consent to that removal
and in order to do that you obviously
have to come up with a very good
resettlement program something that is
rarely if ever done
the World Bank found this just appalling
even though indigenous peoples represent
a substantial minority not quite half
but something approaching it of the 40
to 80 million people who have been
affected by dams and forced to move and
very often almost always what happens
when these indigenous peoples are forced
to move and remember they've been living
in these remote river valleys where only
a dam would would want to be they many
cases have been there for hundreds or
thousands of years and suddenly they're
being told to move so their cultures get
shattered
that has happened time and time again
they often end up on the fringes of
cities as beggars or pulling rickshaws
or something like that instead of at
least being given a stake in the dam
which is another point that's in those
recommendations there are ways that they
can at least have some of the bounty
that the dam represents whether it's
becoming fishermen in the reservoir or
taking part in maintenance there are
plenty of ways that can be offered and
almost never are so those are the two
extremes there are quite a few others in
there most of them a very commonsensical
could you say a few words about
arguments that seem to really carry
weight with the World Bank arguments
against dams or arguments for more
sensible planning of dams you know of
the many things that you Chronicle
tonight that are issues around dams
which ones speak the most loudly to the
World Bank the responsible people at the
world land the World Bank I mean in
terms of building them why they build
them in spite of what I've been talking
about which criticisms against dams do
they find the most uh do they give most
credibility to well there are two major
kinds of criticism having to do with it
social impacts and its environmental
impacts they've hired anthropologists
who study the social impacts they've
invited many scientists to study the
environmental impacts and they certainly
given lip service to both and their
policies reflect an acknowledgement of
both and indeed if their policies were
to be followed they're not they're not I
don't think quite what's required but
they go a good part of the way there but
they're they're never followed what ends
up happening is that once they loan
their money to a host country to build
the dam and that dam starts to come up
they lose their leverage they have the
most leverage precisely before they've
given the money but by the time they've
given
way all their money or their loan I
should say they have no leverage left
and so the host government usually ends
up ignoring what they want to do so even
with the best of wills what what is in
their policies doesn't happen thank you
can in a moment before in response to
another question you mentioned that the
the World Bank found this appalling and
were you referring to the displacement
of the indigenous people and sort of in
unjust treatment of those people no no I
think what I was referring to was the
the world Commission on dams report and
it's 26 recommendations they they found
it appalling that there were that the
recommendations were so rigorous and
require required much more of them than
they hope to have to do yes could I
thought my question then we can you say
who gains from the dams who are the
beneficiaries an interesting question
indeed who gains even when dams are
disasters there are people who benefit
usually they are people in the central
government and the central government
itself in there comes from the bank or
from other donors a huge infusion of
money that suddenly is going through the
coffers of some developing country and
so suddenly it has a tremendous amount
of leverage it can be used as patronage
sometimes very often their bribes
involved so just in that form
governments love them very often almost
also invariably
there have to be roads built to these
dams and so they get some infrastructure
built for them there is a kind of
classic book called the anti politics
machine about this tiny country of
lassoo - which is entirely surrounded by
South Africa and it was a study by an
anthropologist of a World Bank
development project in the mid-1970s
that
thing to do with dams but in a way the
conclusions apply just as well to dams
it had to do with enhancing and
rationalizing livestock production among
people who lived in the mountains of the
zoo to a very poor country and involved
building roads out to these people and
figuring out ways to make markets for
these people's cattle it sounds
reasonable to us perhaps but the cattle
didn't have the same relationship to
these people that we might imagine
they weren't strictly economic things
they there were something that a kind of
symbolic value they were key in the
culture and they didn't want to have any
part of this and so the program
collapsed and yet in the government's
terms the the project was a big big
success they got all this money they got
these roads at the end of the roads they
put police stations so that they had
control in parts of the country where
they never had before
so they loved it now on top of that of
course there are the builders who very
often are from developed countries
indeed that's often a recommend a
requirement of these projects that it is
the first world countries who get the
donors who get to supply the builders
the the creative force and so first
world countries benefit from these
projects sometimes more than the host
countries do yep
I really enjoyed your prose I'm looking
forward to reading the whole book I have
a couple of questions
I'm understood locally here I've
understood that the water table of Napa
Valley is something near and dear to all
of us is diminishing and I'm wondering
if you have any statistics on that no
that's not something I do in to roving
around the world I have neglected in
every okay and I'm wondering if you know
when a swans lake nasser is going to
fill with sediment do you track that one
um you know the statistics Dan a very
from damn - damn indeed as I said with
Hoover Dam it's 1,100 years but that's
chiefly because Glen Canyon is behind
Coover so that the sediment that would
be filling behind Hoover is instead
filling behind Glen Canyon the Aswan Dam
I don't know but I can tell you that
there are dams in China that have filled
extremely rapidly the the most extreme
case is a dam on the Yellow River which
is the silkiest River in the world by a
factor of nine and this dam on the day
it opened for business was already 1/3
full of sediment so it was only going to
last a fifth a few years and even then
it already lost a lot of its
effectiveness and yet despite that I
mean clearly this is a case of absurd
planning but despite that dint get build
yeah I was under the impression that the
Lake Nasser was going to fill up fairly
rapidly and finally I'm just wondering
about deconstruction is there a
deconstruction movement going on is that
how is that going in the United States
there are more dams being decommissioned
as it said of being taken down then
there are dams being built that United
States was always in the vanguard of dam
building and are of dam history it used
to be in terms of dam building and now
it's in terms of taking them down but
even though that's true all of the dams
that have been taken down so far are
small it's very hard to take down a
large
and estimates are that the expense is
about what it costs to put it up in the
first place so it can't be done easily
and in addition to that when there is a
sediment that has gathered behind the
dam there's a question of what you do
with it you can't simply suddenly
release it down the river or you'll just
destroy a lot of the river and very
often the sediment is filled with toxins
if there is mining upstream there can be
tailings if there's agriculture there
can be agricultural runoff pesticides
fertilizer so it is a great quandary
about what to do with all this sediment
pumping it out is usually too expensive
so it has to be planned very carefully
you can in some cases if it isn't too
toxic you can gradually release it but
it's just one of the other dilemmas
that's involved with decommissioning in
spite of all that decommissioning is
gaining momentum there are calls for
taking down four dams on the Snake River
tributary of the Columbia because they
stand in the way of a lot of salmon and
that would be wonderful but as long as
the Bush administration is in power
that's not going to happen the the Bush
administration has said no there is an
interesting movement to take down the
dam at Hetch Hetchy the Vout the valley
next to Yosemite and that's
O'Shaughnessy dam that's three hundred
and twelve feet high that would be the
largest dam ever taken down if it does
and there have been studies that show
that it would be easy to arrive
relatively easy to replace the water
that's stored behind it in the small
amount of energy that it generates but
it would be very expensive to take it
down it would cost a few billion dollars
and there is a question as to whether
that's the best use of a few billion
dollars whether it might be better spent
on other environmental projects but
that's a very interesting effort and
it's tempting to before it for the
simple fact that it's construction
marked the beginning of the
environmental movement John Muir fought
against that dam the Sierra Club was
formed in reaction to that
and of course that was the environmental
movement's first of many great failures
it would be nice to see that trend
reversed by the taking down of the dam
and of course the biggest dam that's
talked about in terms of being taken
down is Glen Canyon Dam which in the
1980s went through one episode where it
rumbled very ominously and came rather
close to a major failure which didn't
happen but now there is a lot of effort
to to claim that it ought to be taken
down water has already dropped so low
because of drought that about I think
two-thirds of the canyon behind it are
already exposed and it's doubtful that
it will ever be full again so it might
not be a bad idea I think like one of
the other questioners I found your prose
to be very powerful and I wondered how
you experienced writing about
environmental issues and and you know
the uniqueness of your particular style
if you could say a little bit about that
I mean it's a very subjective question
but what what you felt like you're able
to bring to it and what was special to
you about writing about it well you know
I think of writing as a kind of
performance even though the results
aren't apparent until afterwards and as
I write I approach it in the way a
performer might might think of his work
a stage performers they are a dancer I
try to to make every sentence have
energy I try to make sure that there's
movement in action but there's got to be
passion to begin with and this is a
subject that I feel passionate about
that's not something that you can
manufacture and I hope that that that
shows in the book it I felt so
privileged so thrilled to be able to
write about this to go to all these
places to to see Victoria Falls the the
widest waterfall in the world and get to
describe it and
a lagoon at the mouth of the River
Murray that's 90 miles long that has
been terribly damaged it now has about
1/10 of the fish it once had because of
all the diversions that have happened
upstream and yet it's an extraordinary
place and an Aboriginal who had lived
there when he was a trial took me to see
that a abandoned fish trap that was
there just an extraordinary thing and
that was just a pile of rocks and it now
had one hole in it where the aboriginals
had breached it the last time that they
left it and what would happen was this
this lagoon is title so when the rocks
were back in place the water would rise
up over this trap and bring the fish
there and then the water would drop back
down again trapping the fish well the
aboriginals very considerately when they
left for the last time and when they
left each time just breached that wall
so that fish wouldn't get trapped and I
thought that was an amazing thing to see
and so I was as grim as it was to see
just the remnants of this I was
delighted to have the chance to to write
about it and so it really I just I felt
gratified to be able to write about
something that's really so important
that and that we need to face in the
world yeah
I'm struck and heartened by the care
that was given to the construction of
the Commission in terms of
representatives of all the different
viewpoints in terms of dam building as
I'm struck with the care that the
restorer Hetch Hetchy movement is
bringing to considering all the
interests of all the stakeholders and
really looking for win-win outcomes
across the board but in both of these
cases the Commission report and all the
restore Hetch Hetchy things and other
movements to decommission other dams
what's being said and what who's hearing
the information that we need to hear
about conservation and overpopulation ah
well that's where Katrina perhaps has a
role to play you know a lot of the
environmental movement has consisted of
environmentalists talking to each other
I don't think that's possible any longer
there have been lots of dire predictions
made now one of them has come true and I
don't think it will be the last one
suddenly we've been told in a very
dramatic way that if we don't pay
attention this is what will happen so I
think that whether we like it or not
that that era of just trying to tune out
this stuff has come to an end whether
will will marshal the resources both
financial and emotional to deal with it
is another question but these things are
real global warming is real we're
starting to experience the consequences
now and indeed that hurricane in its
intensity it may have been one of them
so there's no turning away from this I
don't believe
well thank you very much it's it's been
a pleasure to do this
[Applause]